[Music]
welcome back to et live's celebration of
all things comic-con now ash and i have
already talked all about how much we
love marvel but we've got to give
lots of love to dc comics as well
yes especially my lady diana prince
because we already should have seen 80s
diana in wonder woman 1984.
here i am so bummed i really really want
to know what is going to be happening
next to her in that movie
well we do have a little bit of a
surprise because e.t caught up with gal
gadot and patty jenkins back in december
at a comic-con in brazil
to get the scoop on all things wonder
woman 1984.
take a look what a treat i get both of
you we're so excited to be here
[Music]
where do we find uh your character where
do we find it
um so diana has been around you know in
the first movie we got to
um to to establish wonder woman
and to tell the journey of diana prince
becoming wonder woman right
and in this uh story
we meet her in 1984 she's been around
she's been helping mankind
you know doing what she feels she needs
to do her calling
pretty lonely because she lost some of
her teammates along the
over the years and then something
crazy is about to happen to her
now after you saw this film a cut maybe
like
one of the first cuts of this film i
hear
you cry is that accurate yes and i'm not
an easy crier
no uh just to you know save my uh
pride baby folks when i'm pregnant i'm
not the type of women who watch
commercials and crying
but you didn't do that for the first one
but you didn't no i had such a strong
reaction
to this movie why uh and it cut me off
guard
why um i think it's
it's i can't tell you what happened in
the movie that made me cry i can just
say it was the very beginning
but i've never seen that all of a sudden
i wasn't the girl
wonder woman the actress the producer
who wore in set and were there when
everything was shot
i was little girl
from a suburb in israel watching
all by myself in the cinema which is for
itself a surreal experience
watching this thing and i've seen this
amazing
woman girl doing this amazing things
and i did not expect that we're doing
something that's
that we hope is gonna have an impact but
it hasn't it's very impactful on us
already
so touchwood it's a good sign and i hope
you're
you and the audience will have the
similar reaction
i mean you really aspire to do something
special
and unique and meaningful well i mean
and it must have maybe it brought
emotions upon you because here you are
suiting up for the second time
in this iconic role and you're a mom of
two daughters
it is for the girls but you can't we
can't
reach the place where we're going to
stop talking about females like
we can't just empower women only by
focusing on women we also need to
educate the boys and the men so
you know a young boy that goes to see
the in the cinema this amazing woman
that does does those amazing things
that he can't believe a woman could do
that right you know what i mean so it
goes both ways
and you guys have done such a great job
pairing up these two fearless women
i mean just taking on the big screen
you know i think every time i make a
movie i'm trying to make a masterpiece
like that's what you
you'll never get there you'll never feel
that you did but that's
always what you're trying to do i
started to see what i felt like the
second movie could be its
own movie okay so on stand alone it's
totally it is a
it's it has to do it's the same
character and there's no we don't break
time continuity it's not a reboot so
it's a sequel in that way but it's not a
sequel to a story
it's its own story the world needs you
i am aiming for this movie to be better
in every way and i feel like we aspired
to make something
that we felt was grand and fantastic and
something you'd want to go see in the
theater
and you know we did something that i
think is super exciting it was
so incredible to watch because we went
to real locations and we shot real
people doing real incredible sequences
on wires and and a lot of the wire rigs
we did no one's ever done before because
no one's ever
the wires have gotten so sophisticated
but it's gone out of vogue of shooting
that way
i got it i feel so i feel so lucky we
got to make this massive grand film and
we are flashing back to 1984 so perhaps
that's why we're taking a little
throwback to some of these
means of filming so yeah can't wait to
see the big hair
you